heyyo kitties I'm we saw sirs we saw a
Hotel Transylvania I scare me white you
were already pretty white I was gonna
say scare me salt and pepper I think
that this is her cameo for Lewis's movie
so look if you see like this shedding
like we didn't have the best hairspray
but yeah so we're here to talk oboe
about Hotel Transylvania 2 which which
we both saw and we should probably
thought of the first one probably it's
fine yeah like this is an arm one of
those movies that got like
panned by critics and they saw you know
Adam Sandler and the makes it oh well I
can't he's the fine actors who play
Dracula and stuff like that and I
thought it was that perfect you know but
I knew Bela Lugosi through the films I
watched with a minute and you sir so we
saw this movie and I like I was looking
forward to seeing the film honestly if I
look really creative and stuff I thought
it looked terrible
but my kids are like no it's actually
really good at it I fully insisted it
was really good I didn't like it as much
as you did I think you were just like
really really playing it up but I was
like ok that actually was good yeah and
I was like it was fine if it wasn't
great it ya know it's not like a
masterpiece or anything like that but
they had great fast animation it was
really creative really stylized really
funny really sweet it has very likable
characters way better than it had any
right to be yeah and especially given I
guess the history of this movies been
production held for years and I'll see
what we got was like pretty
amazing considering the backstory and
well that director who did like Samurai
Jack and everything I guess it's like I
need I can never prisoners I don't know
we're gonna piss off everybody cuz I
can't save the name I always forget how
to say the name and stuff sure people
get spelling out in the comments but
he's a phenomenal talent I mean ever any
animation nut you know a seeing this
guy's work and he's really incredible
so the sequel comes out again could
external on our cubes well I guess we
give it 10 percent more I'll give it
that
57 I think you know it's perfectly I
would like just as good as the first one
okay
yeah no in some ways it's better than
the first one in some ways it's not but
it I I don't get it I mean I was
wondering it's got the funny thing is
this one has better reviews at least the
last time I looked at better reviews in
the first one don't know well the first
one is being seen as like a Halloween
classic I do still think there are jokes
I heard a fault Joe Gatto it's totally
brings it down another 50 months I
literally like and some people like well
it's rotten tomatos I mean if you get
50% of rotten tomatoes that's not that
bad well it's not that good either yeah
and it's not the it's not the fact
that's only 50% because sometimes it can
be 50% a lot of people are on the edge
of like well it's you know it's not
exactly great and Rotten Tomatoes will
kind of rank that as like a you know
maybe a negative but hey there are some
reviews that I was reading that was like
I I just couldn't believe it
where it's this like it used to be a
competition for who had the worst
animated films out there and and move
over Rio so long turbo now we have hotel
- oh baby oh - there was a review out
there like that and there's a number of
reviews that are so I'm like I get how
if it's not your thing and you know I
could only see that like it's a little
slap sticky and it's Jabbar everyone
yeah it's definitely aimed at younger
kids it's not like what there's still
there's still somebody yeah told jokes
and the animation is great and the
characters are great and I don't know I
still think there's a lot of really
great stuff for adults in it as well you
know beyond just like they're in jokes
and personal but its base level is
definitely see queuing under 10 its
namagiri
it's not like as much of a family like
it's sibling under 10 which is fine but
the degree to which some critics are
just on this movie I'm like I
could get if you don't like it but
you're you're acting like this is bottom
of a barrel
I'm like we're not even close to bottom
of the barrel if you tried I'm like I'm
reading this review like that it's just
like oh this is just about Smurfs
tickets I can't believe it and meanwhile
Alvin then the Chipmunks the road to
chip is just around the bend
I'm like come on well to be fair I don't
think it's can you give reviews either
like you want to tell me that this is
like bottom of the barrel like merits
Despicable Me 2 came out and we liked it
fine but that's clearly an unfocused
mess it's funny and we enjoy it but it's
like it's an unfocused mess and this it
might be it's just light years better in
light years more thought-out and more
caring and more interesting and more
interesting more funny characters I
remember and want to know what's gonna
happen - and the second one well we had
the minions we like the minions
characters are passable but it's like
this is like light-years beyond like
that I don't know what even though I
don't know what the reason is I don't
know if it is the Adam Sandler found
really wondering where because like Adam
Sandler's name is attached
oh just and don't get wrong we I saw the
first five minutes of my mind was made
up when I saw the words Adam Sandler
know we've been brutal to Adam Sandler
don't get me wrong I mean he says when
he totally when if items totally
deserved but no it is not fair when
somebody who is talented who's turned
out a lot and talented stuff but is
talented you know hath wrote this stars
in it and turns out a really creative
really funny really a lot of effort is
put into this and it's like oh I just
I've made up my mind about this person
and kind of his crew like the David
Spade Jon Lovitz Kevin James grey it's
like Oh any of those who were in this
movie yeah no that's why I'm saying that
they because they're all here and
they've been connected to bad projects
it's like well then it must be bad but
it's like no these people can come
together and they can make a good
project and they have and I think like I
said if you don't like and we're like I
feels like they're like Judas on my
public Facebook like it's all gonna be
like well you actually like an atom
family I'm like can at least go beyond
my one hand on Adam Sandler films I've
liked yeah so I there's one white that
doesn't mean though I have to sit here
and say that little Nicki's a good movie
it's piece of where that ridiculous
great movie no it's not but so I could
either be the enemy sailor factor I know
this is just like a Pixar kind of better
DreamWorks thing where it's is like the
bar for some critics is so raise it to
just be a decent kids movies like oh
well it's no inside-out yeah it's no Toy
Story it's like what the is like
this you're you're comparing it to way
up high it's kinda like watching you
know Beauty and the Beast and then
watching a Tom and Jerry cartoon trust
me well that clearly was no beauty in
the beast it's like yeah that's the
point
assholes and oranges guys um so yeah I I
don't know but when you want to try to
like tell me that oh we're scraping
bottom of the barrel on the Hotel
Transylvania 2 is well the worst and
it's like not even a prestigious high
mark not not even yeah no I'm with you I
can totally see someone not liking this
film might be like you know some of
those you know we are yeah we love
slight love slapstick side of the beam
we love Tom and Jerry we love some of
the old Warner Brothers cartoons you
know so yes it's more towards us those
kids who like that but the jokes that
doesn't mean you know yeah good jokes
and these are good care here's the thing
they're they're good jokes and good
characters but my point is that you have
to acknowledge when something does
slapstick good even if you don't like
slapstick it's like okay there's the
Three Stooges and then there's you know
really bottom of the barrel it's like
within the realm of slapstick this was
really good slapstick and if you can't
even acknowledge that it's like a piece
of then I don't think you should be
reviewing this movie or I gotta just say
that I'm not the target audience so take
that with a grain of salt and most of
the reasons that I read didn't they just
were like oh it's and I'm like what
what and I think like with you know
Roger Ebert I think was talking about
like the Devil's Rejects and he said
look this is not my movie and I don't
get into this type of style or genre
ever but I know this is a genre I know
it is a style and it's to be respected
if you're into this you will like this
fine you know this is the kind of
mean-spirited torture porn thing and it
does it well it's just not my thing and
I'm to be fair he was even saying I
don't even know if I'm qualified to even
buick as i'm so well I think the lily
upcoming the upcoming goosebumps movie
as an example like well it's getting
decent reviews are you gonna like it I'm
like well I don't know for sure but I'm
like if I were to guess I might not
really but I don't think I'm the target
audience did I didn't watch goosebumps I
didn't like the original goosebumps that
much it didn't do I was the wrong
generation wrong age so it's a PG movie
aimed specifically I think I know people
watch the show or a new generation yeah
but I would be the first to admit they
if I see them like okay this just was
not meant for me yes I mean it's like
Harry Potter those are not the worst
movies or anything but it's just like
I'd like this has a huge following 7a
was rough to get through no that's not
saying like this is just something
that's like this just isn't for me you
know but it's like if it's you fine now
I'm not gonna say it's like bad or
poorly made it's just not my thing so
the movie itself is good ya know it's a
I think it's very well made very funny
there's a few and there's definitely
times we're like some jokes fall flat
and even sort of the moral is like I
think anyone can get the moral but the
way they go about is very Lion King or
Disney where it's like well now that
I've learned my lesson
let me get everything that I try you
know I'm knocking everything that these
bad deeds have the thing was it was
co-written by Adam Sandler and I think
it was Robert Smigel Michael yeah yeah
you can kind of tell they wrote
themselves into a corner because the
movie I thought overall was pretty well
written literally up until the last 15
minutes I do I see about maybe 15
minutes before the movie yeah and it's
not bad but it's you know we we gotta
wrap this up it clearly was like oh well
we wrapped ourselves into a corner like
you could just see them bouncing ideas
off them on Adam Sandler somebody's
images why don't we just have them all
beat the hell out of each other and then
everybody gets what they want and yeah
it's still funny it's pretty much the
the the finale was very much aimed at
kids and very slapstick the only thing I
didn't like about it is the morale was
kind of weird but a lot of movies I find
have done that like kung fu pan is a
great example where it's all about the
fact that he isn't a kung fu master that
is his own thing and then somehow solves
the problem by being a kung fu master
well that kind of shat on them all ya
know yeah you know and this movie does
something very similar but I think I
think it's the same thing like watching
Lion King or Cinderella a lot of these
Disney films where it's like okay are
they technically breaking the moral yeah
but I think it's very clear what the
moral is I think most kids can catch on
and I think my thing is it didn't wreck
the whole movie there's so occasionally
I will find a movie where the ending is
so bad it will wreck the whole movie
yeah this didn't wreck the whole no it
didn't come the only the other thing
that bugged me about the ending was I
thought the slapstick of all places in
the finale was what's kind of wait maybe
we just saw it everywhere else it was it
was way too the animation everything was
way too busy there was too much going on
there was very little focus I couldn't
make out half the time what the hell was
going on it felt very rushed like
literally some I don't know if this
happened it almost like the studio came
in it was like we need this thing now
yeah by Halloween or whatever and yeah
meanwhile some poor guy behind the
computers is getting horse whipped to
death but they pop so I was gonna say
there is in it when you start this movie
off you're gonna think oh my god is this
gonna be nothing but excuses to have pop
songs no but there are about two or
three times where they are say about
three or four times oh yeah painfully
forced in and it's just like oh that was
stops and they're short but it's what I
can see I can literally see some record
executive rolling around naked in piles
you see the contract like Mike's right
there like you know Dracula's talking to
his grandson he's like I want you to fly
kid dances a little basic oh okay if I
bust a move will you try flying it's
like what it's only if you you
literally could hear them kachunk
kachunk kachunk every song that came out
yeah so that that was painful but like
nothing else like I said apart from a
joke being like when I could have been a
strong girl and whether I just as much
hard as the first one yeah you know and
it had one there was one clear advantage
to this one which is hate
Jonathan
I hate nineties kid cliche care chemist
eros Assange say his name I know Andy
Samberg er I think that's a yeah he did
the digital swords front shorts III
don't know who's playing with him it's
not that that's the one thing you like
really hate her with a passion from the
first film yeah and it's not even so
much the the voice acting is okay like
is it it's just the way the character
was written drawn everything about him
I'm like this is so 1996 like
it's not even if I like when I saw Hotel
Transylvania 1 when Jonathan showed up I
literally thought it might a different
movie like this turned into a 1996 film
but it probably wasn't development that
well maybe the problem it may be exactly
what happened yeah they never updated
that part but and to be fair to this
movie cuz I hated him in the first movie
when they cut him out a lot he's when
that quickly porn the cook was gonna
kill him in the first movie was like oh
thank god Mavis can do way better and I
still don't understand what the she
sees but it this one there is so much
less of him and to be honest the few
times he's actually in there he's not
that annoying so I was like yes no but
in fact there's a scene there's two
things I noticed in this see one is when
there's the kind of get to that point
where it's like oh no everybody's sad
and the plan didn't work or whatever and
you think people are gonna whatever not
see each other or something Bad's gonna
happen but again they make it short they
keep up the jokes and and it works fine
but do you remember like you know that
maybe this is walking away there's this
big conflict between her and her father
and then you just see him sir walking
away two of the sad face like yeah I'm
still in the movie - did you get that
feeling I was just like oh yeah like
he's a thing in this so yeah they cut
him down a lot but no here's an example
of why I think this film is so funny and
Willy deserves more I thought we were a
vegan I thought we were gonna get kicked
out of the cinema because I think we
were laughing louder than the kids yes
no we were cuz this is really legit fine
stuff it is one there's a
seen where and I'm not giving anything
away but there's there's a conflict
between like the Dracula and Davis and
you know that it's gonna you know Jackie
O's trying to do something he shouldn't
be and he's kind of endangering the kid
through it as well um and you know he's
lying about it so Mike gets to a point
where she says you know are you lying
about this you were here the whole time
yeah absolutely we know what's coming we
know that something's gonna be shown to
prove him wrong it's gonna be a little
bit of a laugh that does happen she
shows video saying that happen but the
extra mile that go is not only DC video
of him and dangering the kid that
somebody filmed but you see a mixed
video that somebody did on YouTube
saying this line that you almost missed
where he just says like a little
throwaway joke about Mavis about the
mother and then like minutes played over
and over and over to this music and it's
done through all this editing and it's
hilarious and that is going the extra
mile I think the key to is the the side
characters really made it I love
Frankenstein I love the Wolfman the
mommy yeah they're all and I think
they're even way more entertaining in
this film for when they have more of a
connection they have more of a
connection and they also they kind of
shortened the character list I felt like
there were more characters in the first
one and then I'm sure they figured out
which ones were the five well like the
cookies yard but the Polito Jon Lovitz
is a really funny so yeah I don't know I
thought it was good I'll tell you the
other thing that I think that I mean not
great but I'll tell you it see this is
why I think this film and the first one
are gonna last and people are gonna
watch these are gonna watch them every
Halloween and they're gonna really enjoy
them is it's not just the jokes it's not
just the creativity and that it's
surrounded in Halloween I mean all the
classic monsters are there and
everything but there is this totally
believable likable heart to it it is
very sweet and everybody's know there
told me even though they're twisted and
they're weird and they're into all a
psychotic stuff it's Adams it's like The
Addams Family in that they still really
like each other and they like being
around each other and they share this
happiness and that's part of the joke is
that they share what many people can
serve be very loving and kind over the
city
dick crazy mean-spirited stuff but they
still really legitimately love you and
better work off each other that's what
makes them work because it's not it's
not a great despite all of its problems
and both films have a lot of problem is
it's never gonna be a great way there's
never gonna be like on the same level as
Pixar you know this isn't a
Miyazaki movie but in its own little
world then there's a little place it
carved out for itself it's the heart
that really sold it for me yeah I mean
like I said I'm like what it was done
I'm like you know what you it's the A
for effort it's like you you weren't
always successful in every joke but you
guys did it with so much passion that
that there's passion beginning to end in
these movie it carries you a lot farther
than than something so soulless like
Smurfs around Chipmunks or you
know any of these other ones and so I
wish I wish more people would see this I
wish I would skip like you know
like Smurfs and Alvin and the Chipmunks
and what they do well I mean that they
made a sequel a sequel did well also I
mean that I would not mind if they put
this amount of effort and creativity
into every single one of these films I
mean I don't mind seeing more of them I
mean usually it's like oh come on you
should stop while your head and stuff
but it's like these films are so
creative and so likable and I love I
love these care what does it matter I
wanna know what they're gonna happen how
they're gonna interact with others
here's something that I think is also
worth noting which is the other one was
in development hell yes but they had so
long to work on the story in this and
that when you consider when the last one
came out the short amount of time till
we made it to this one wasn't the twist
on that Popeye movie right the director
like he was gonna do a Popeye movie they
had this clip that looked amazing and
they're like scrap it something happened
and then he got this movie so it's like
man is this is another situation where
the amount of time was so short that you
would have thought well this is gonna be
the make a quick buck movie and
it wasn't no but man the reviews would
make you think of it ya know I
it really legitimately does not seem
fair you know it just because somebody
puts out there's two there's two films
I've seen this week from people that
usually do not put out very good
material that put up too thin and one a
Sandler and the other Shyamalan with the
visit okay and he'll for
yeah yeah no no but Shyamalan the visit
is getting bare reviews in this and
again I really don't think that's fair
cuz I think this one really went further
with its idea and this is fun yeah I
still recommend it but I think this
one's just from beginning to end I'm
like no this is just the better made
film yeah people are like oh but it's
it's Sandler we don't like him and stuff
like that so far two jokes no never
oh it's David Spade Jon Lovitz is that
we don't like those people and they're
all together no I'm gonna hate this and
they just decide before they go in that
they're not gonna like it
no Brooks is in this oh you used to be
cool yeah it's one of those things where
it's like you know if you're going in he
may have been the only thing that was
kind of like you could have taken over
the left that like they they sort of
make it sound like it's gonna be about
him but then it's kind of like no you
just--come say at the end which is like
yeah I'm we feel like he wasn't bad or
anything that's like this but no it's
one thing if you go in thinking you're
not if you go in not wanting to like
this movie or think you're not gonna
like it
you probably won't I don't know if it's
gonna win you over but if you looked at
the trailers and sort of the creativity
and say okay like you know I could get
into this idea this could be fun I think
you'll want it if you are like the first
one you'll love yeah if you liked the
first one or at least one to the first
row like that wasn't bad it more the
same like and some you know good yeah in
some ways in some ways better and in
some ways there's a few problems but you
know as I said I thought it was really
solid pretty much up until last 15
minutes like even the last 15 minutes
because that I had a little bit problem
with the first film - with the again
it's it's not quite the light reveal but
it's kind of the well this can't work as
societies as you can so one character
has to tell the other I don't love you I
don't like you and stuff and it it drags
a little bit and there's something
almost like that we just want to I think
all we can say is that it still keeps
the jokes going it still keeps it funny
but it's but it never distracts too much
from the character or the situation I
guess my only thing is the whole moral
was based around well you should have
the right in the freedom to be whatever
you want to be in this net but
then what they exactly wanted to have
happen regardless like it happens yeah
yeah if it really muted that message yes
I agree but I still think again I don't
know if that's what the job we're doing
it it just without one thing I'm like
man this came so close and then it just
kind of was like they didn't they didn't
commit to it yeah the the strength of
the movie is the comedy and the
characters and the heart and all of that
is still there the message you can get
and you can still pick up what it is but
you're right it's a yawn it is it's
right it's the same estoy it's like the
ending to Toy Story 2 where the whole
thing was like no toys should be outside
and be enjoyed and we should all get
along and this and then and it's not
fair what happens to toys or wrap
difference of what they do they they
like totally take the poor prospector
and
kick him out like so he has some
miserable existence with some crazy girl
I'm like well you know for something
that was all about like teamwork and
getting along that was like shitty like
he wouldn't do it though he was forcing
them against their will so that that's
what I guess I don't know I find I find
all the Toy Story movies are kind of
strange in the way it like plays that
aspect up of like getting a log and then
it always seems to come down to revenge
into it yeah that the first one was
perfect just the kid applause yeah
totally makes one's the first one was
fine do you and that kid well maybe they
doomed him to a lot of therapy yeah
didn't do them to a miserable experience
given mr. muffinz the second one in
particular Bobby the third one I was
like that bear was so messed up
and I said okay like I can kind of see
this but but yeah I we really enjoyed it
it's not like a comic masterpiece or
anything but I can really see people
watching these films every Halloween I
know I am it just gets me in the mood
for Halloween and and it's very funny
and very sweet and very creative and
sailors not obnoxious in it
no and I and he he can do both the funny
and he can do the hard and he can even
do a funny voice all three of those work
in these movies nah and I and he hath
wrote it I mean it's it's if I wanted
this you would Adam Sandler
it's paid is not that obnoxious event
yeah literally
someone is the bane of my existence like
growing up in high school like the David
Spade movies and stuff I'm just like
like I I could do him justice very funny
so I think this movie goes the extra
mile in terms of the comedy and the
heart and the creativity um like I said
there's there's Fault in it and if
you're looking to not like it if you're
looking like dude I don't think I'm
gonna like this you probably won't but
if you see the idea I think this could
be a fun idea it'll be exactly that'll
be a fun idea and I think I'll even go
but if you're reading reviews and
they're like this is the death of
animation no tell me she'll go far don't
write them and tell them to shut
the it but yeah it's we both really
really enjoyed it it shows our passion
for because I just realize we never did
like do the open for this we just sort
of started we should do like a little
sibling rivalry opening vows just like
no I just really want to talk about this
because the critics are not being fair
they are not they don't say I don't like
your little stupid openings anyways Wow
there you go hey we'll get rid of it
good fine it's decided
great we won't have an ending either cut